chef David Chang is the creative
powerhouse behind Netflix's ugly
delicious and the popular mama Foucault
restaurant the James Beard award-winning
chef opened his first restaurant back in
2004
Bon Appetit calls his mama Foucault
Empire the most important restaurant in
America you go David Chang I didn't know
that David either is a host and
executive producer of the new Netflix
series it's called breakfast lunch and
dinner he eats his way through different
cities with celebrities including Seth
Rogen who was hilarious Chrissy Teigen
always funny Lena wait cool and Kate
McKinnon
she was knockout too they learned about
food culture and each other in the
process in the first episode Chang
visits a doughnut shop in Rogen's
hometown of Vancouver Li's I want to go
there yeah just roll it and sugar you
stick it on there from the sugar you get
it from the actual doughnut it's soft
crunchy and either some of the city from
the jelly I swear to God I never thought
of a jelly doughnut as like a perfect
food chef David Chang is with us first
on CBS this morning you know I learned
on your show that stressed his desserts
spelled backwards isn't that good that's
various desserts felt backward so this
is the thing David I think you've got
the dream job I watched your show and I
thought oh god I would love to do this
so your premise is through three meals
what happens we just have good
conversation they explore the city and
it's a sense of discovery about the
ghast or myself or the foods that were
eating so you pick a guest they get to
pick the city mm-hmm and how long does
it take to shoot because you're with
them all day long we try to do it all
within a day yeah sometimes it carries
over the next day but it's a long one
day but it's a good day because there's
at least three meals for sure it's
amazing how many moments yeah creates
yeah in conversation like the best ice
breaker there is yeah you'd be delicious
food is the like everyone can understand
what that might feel like or taste like
their late friend Anthony Bourdain of
course paved the way for a lot of the
shows like this how did he influence how
did his show and what he did influence
what you're doing with your last show
and now this one well Tony show all the
shows that he did I think influenced
anyone that did food or travel or food
and culture yeah it just set the bar for
everyone so whatever we tried to do to
do it differently was to still pay
homage to what he did for all of us I
was struck by something you said in a
conversation with Kate McKinnon in the
show when you say I fundamentally don't
believe I'm talented at anything because
I have to work so much more than anyone
else like cooking doesn't come naturally
to me true that was a surprise to me too
we use it but you don't think of
yourself that you don't give yourself as
talented anything I think I'm a really
good cook but there are other people
that started out were better than I am I
just had to work like tortoise wins the
race in my opinion Yeah right and
cooking is the one thing that I know
that a lack of natural talent doesn't
really have anything to do with where
you're gonna wind up if you just work
very hard at it I'll committed to it
yeah I think I'm a result of that really
you don't think you have I get a certain
excitement for food or a palette or just
a kind of big bear openness to the world
something that makes it magical I think
maybe I'm curious because I wasn't so
good at it yeah does that connect then
to when you because you've said Momofuku
is as you know as acclaimed as it is you
said almost everything we've done has
been a failure from the get-go this is
also true so you sail yer doesn't
intimidate you
I think you can't learn anything truly
without messing things up and
experiencing some pain and suffering and
try not to make that same mistake twice
and to really push yourself at least for
myself to to get to another level I have
to experience something that is
sometimes scary and frightening and to
work through that was it scary and
frightening to be with Seth Rogen who
you said was the best marijuana joints
ever and so we see the two of you
smoking marijuana and driving I was
worried about that day but how'd that
work well and you guys were really
smoking it too
my mom is gonna be so bad it was a fun
day but it was set up so there was
nothing to be worried about in terms of
how we were driving I can't explain the
technical
the car was hitched to another vehicle
but it was but my point is you get to
learn a lot about the people who you're
working who you're who you're going
you're experiencing things with you and
chrissy teigen you're in morocco and
somebody says hey Jackie Chan and you
just sort of laugh it off and say see
people can still be races all around the
world yeah
you just make everything a delight with
you well I just think that's the best
way to travel is to just experience
things be out of your comfort zone and
then just see another place and see the
people there and it doesn't mean that
maybe they haven't seen an Asian man
before yeah you know it's interesting
you said in 2030 you hope you rich man
okay go ahead no I mean who sit at this
table you know they want to be
remembered for all time they want to be
immortal and you know the Washington
Post recently that you hope by 2030
people say David who would be forgotten
it's incredibly foolish to want to be
remembered when you die like it doesn't
matter right like I think if I do my job
however it may be if it's good enough
then it becomes commonplace yeah it's
not remembered anymore and and that is
through food I think and being a Korean
man an Asian American in this country I
think if I can help open doors in a way
where other people can do it like it's a
good thing my job is successful if
people don't remember well it's a great
show David Chang thank you so much for
being your breaking now call them Hugo's
dad dinner is streaming now on netflix